every step is a struggle for detail
endeavor an accident has left her with
extremely stiff muscles that's why her
dog Bentley helps her carry her shopping
in this handy satchel he's also able to
pick up her crutches if necessary
Bentley is more than just a domestic pet
he's a butler companion and protector
he's restored some independence to
DeLand even day-to-day tasks like
grocery shopping are often a challenge
for did lent were she to lose her
balance she'd be helpless without her
dog he's trained to help her get back on
her feet what she can't do he does she
says this helps eliminate the stigma of
being disabled disabled people are
sometimes treated like social outcasts
or even lepers she says it's a taboo
subject people tend to stare and look
away in embarrassment and having a dog
makes things easier for me I'm a woman
with a dog rather than with a crutch on
the way home from the market in the
Bavarian town of oflet's Heusen she
explains why it's important for her to
be able to drive her car it didn't take
long for her to get back behind the
wheel after her accident 24 years ago a
driver going the wrong way
slammed into the front of her car I used
to spend a lot of time in the mountains
she says but I can't do that anymore
but now I can do other things it's all
about looking at what I can do rather
than getting sad and dwelling on what I
can't it's important to be flexible and
concentrate on new things
the chef's noting a constant fear she
was initially paralyzed by the accident
some nerve functions gradually started
returning but never fully Bentley picks
up the slack if she dropped something in
the kitchen for example he'll jump into
action he knows she's unable to bend
over and pick it up herself a camera
attached to Bentley's back shows just
how enthusiastic he is about his tasks
he is after all a Labrador Retriever
having Bentley around is also a massive
weight off Deathlands husband's mind
he no longer worries about leaving his
wife on her own both are certain that
without the dog their lives after the
accident would be very different
Devlin's husband says the dog stopped
them from getting bored Bentley has
brought some life back into the house
before the accident
I'd been healthy and cheerful but then I
was plunged into depression but now that
we have Bentley our problems no longer
dominate our daily lives
Keith Lin says that before she always
had to ask her husband to get her this
or that or to lift something which can
be annoying the dog has made them both
much more relaxed so where does one go
to find a dog like Bentley who's even
able to get along with cats
the Austrian city of Salzburg has 150
kilometers away
that's where Elizabet fabbing uh runs
one of just three assistants dog schools
in german-speaking Europe she was
inspired by schools in the United States
Sophie a trainer is trying to teach the
young assistance dog Nicholas not to
leave her side that's quite a task when
you're competing with someone on wheels
Nicholas must also learn to respond to
numerous commands Elisabeth fahringer
explains that it's frightening for
wheelchair users if they fall out of
their chairs or if the ground is uneven
or if the battery dies this literally
disables them so it's important that the
dog is there to bark for help each dog
is trained to respond to the needs of
their future owner what they'll be
called on to do could vary wildly it
might be opening a door or putting shoes
on and off not every dog makes the grade
Gabby explains these dogs have to be a
bit like workaholics they have to like
working and always being with their
owners there's plenty of demand for
assistance dogs but at a cost of some
sixteen thousand euros each not everyone
can afford them that's why Elizabet
helps in the search for donors and
sponsors with their support almost 300
people have been matched with
four-legged helpers nicholas is all set
to take on his next task he's been told
to maintain eye contact with Sophie as
she guides him through a narrow passage
this is how he'll be expected to behave
in public areas like supermarket
checkouts Sophie stays in the wheelchair
throughout the exercises in order to
tailor the training to the future owners
specific needs Sophie says that
first-time wheelchair users see things
different perspective because they're
lower down and sitting all of a sudden
there are so many things they no longer
have access to Nicholas and ginger Akali
are being let loose in the world for the
first time today they get driven to a
local shopping mall ordinary dogs are
not allowed in but assistance dogs may
accompany their owners they have to
behave very well shopping at the
supermarket is a serious task ginger
takes a rest but will he manage to deal
with the fact that his owner has
disappeared for a moment
apparently so then it's time to pay
niklas does everything just right
textbook fashion he stays on one side
and turns just when he has to the six
months of training have paid off
this get Vicki's fossil emailed welcome
she says this is because the dogs are
constantly training on Sundays and
public holidays as well it takes a few
hundred hours till they're really ready
to go the next morning the Kyla family
comes to Elizabeth fabbing as kennels to
do what's known as a team quality test
assistance dogs have to pass their exams
to today it's brownies turn but who is
he helping Connie Kyler explains that
she has type 1 diabetes and that her
diabetes service dog brownie alerts her
when her blood sugar levels fluctuate
brownie can tell when they go up or down
he does it with his notes he can
actually smell Connie's blood sugar
level a little later it's all systems go
as soon as brownie jumps up on Connie
she knows something is wrong Connie says
she'll measure her blood sugar now to
see whether brownie was right
some diabetes patients can notice on
their own when their blood sugar gets
too high or low but Connie can't that
puts her at risk of suddenly passing out
Connie says brownie was right the dog
noticed that her blood sugar was too
high and warned her she said that
relieves her of a huge burden and
enables her to react more quickly but
now it's time for another test the
annual service dog certification
check-up assistance dogs are always on
duty and they're aware of the
responsibilities they bear that makes it
hard for brownie to relinquish that
responsibility to leave Connie Kyler on
her own will they let her go
Elizabet Fabio finds nothing to
criticize brownie passes the test with
flying colors and gets his certification
at home with the Kyler's brownie is like
a regular domestic pet but he always
makes sure that Connie is nearby he's a
constant companion Connie says she has a
friend who went jogging with her because
she wanted someone around who knew about
her disability and could help in an
emergency but that limited her freedom
but now she organizes her life around
the dog quite literally he's always on
hand always nearby even at night he
stays close to her bed alert to her
condition but she says she enjoys her
independence husband admits there are
times when the dog isn't welcome when
that's the case the couple can close the
door for a bit of privacy
meanwhile deed land era is taking
Bentley to the hospital where she works
as a psychologist here Bentley is not
only Deadlands service dog
he often helps break the ice when her
patients are reluctant to talk about
their problems she says dogs can be
better than a thousand sessions with a
psychotherapist because a dog is also
good for people in other countries dogs
have been used for therapy for a long
time but it's still a new phenomenon in
Germany
after work DEET lint ever takes Bentley
and the neighbor's dog for a walk they
both get a good workout she says the
dogs brought fun and enjoyment back into
her life she's not so focused on herself
she takes her cue from him his enjoyment
of life is transmitted to her she
explains so her own life is enriched as
well she says she can't even begin to
imagine life without Bentley